Well, we've got a big debate.
That's got the internet buzzing and talking
and it comes from the UK.
Entertainment weekly reports that The Sun
published a story claiming the world's sexiest bald man is,
Prince William
and it was a part of a survey where Mike Tyson
and Jason Statham came in second and third
and the internet was immediately up in arms.
There were calls for like, where's The Rock, Common, LL,
but the fan favorite I guess,
was Stanley Tucci.
I get the Stanley Tucci thing, 'cause he's amazing.
I kind of forgot about him for a little while
until he did that
CNN show where he's cooking in Italy.
Oh I know.
I just want to go to Italy now, I want to eat pasta
He has a nice figure too.
Like it's not a lascivious--
Ooh!
(audience clapping)
Whoa, by the way.
Cheeky!
I get jealous,
I get jealous Drew, I get jealous.
Well gosh, you...
You are just a handsome man,
had to tell.
Thank you.
And next, this is your story, sorry.
Yes, okay Drew, I am very happy and grateful to say
that I have gotten my vaccine shot.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
I did it in Jersey City
with our first lady in New Jersey, Tammy Murphy,
who happened to be a VVA grad, like me.
And the mayor of Jersey City,
we went over to encourage the minority community
to not have hesitancy.
We know that once we have herd immunity
70% in our communities and across the country
this place will be a much better world.
So we're looking forward to that happening
and I encourage everyone to go get their shots like I have.
Yes.
Now, if that wasn't sweet enough,
the deal just got so much sweeter.
I cannot wait.
Delish reports that Krispy Kreme
is giving away a free original glazed donut
to anyone with the vaccination card
and it's not just a one-off,
it's every day for the rest of 2021.
Oh my gosh!
A donut a day does not keep the doctor away,
but it is a sweet sweet treat
that I will be part taking in, hmm,
hmm.
Oh my God.
I ran this morning,
so I'm gonna have two, just so you know.
Thank you Krispy Kreme,
for making getting vaccinated as Tiki said, even sweeter.
Yes it is.
Tiki this is like, literally I just want to--
This is so beautiful.
I just want to lie down on it.
(audience laughing)
It's so beautiful.
Well, we got to talk about the NCAA, it is March madness,
so there has been a ton of great basketball,
but there's also been a huge conversation about
gender disparity
and it all was sparked by Sedona Prince,
a forward for the University of Oregon,
when she posted this on TikTok.
(indistinct chatter)
This one really got me.
Yeah, it should.
So we all know that in 1972,
Title Nine was passed in this country and what that does
is it prevents sex discrimination
to any educational institution that gets federal funds.
And we see this because there are an equal number
of men's scholarship teams as well as
women's scholarship teams.
What gets in people's craw about this for the NCAA
is it's all about money.
The NCAA men's basketball tournament makes $900 million.
The women makes 15,
but it doesn't mean that you can't spend
the same amount of resources to celebrate
these amazing women,
who are doing unbelievable things as well, I mean,
because this is the NCAA and the Division 1 Council,
they should know better.
So kudos to the women in the NCAA tournament
who won't stand for this anymore.
What Sedona did was
showing those pathetic little barbells
next to the men's gym
and her words, it,
it affected me so deeply
and she brought up the COVID testing isn't the same,
the funds aren't the same, the resources,
but the way she did it was just,
I don't know how to say this but it was so
visually compelling and matter of fact, it's like
I would hire the best filmmaker in the world
and they probably couldn't have done it that well.
It's like the cynic, it's like she was a New Yorker.
Like she had the cynic,
the cynicism part of that down perfectly
and look, women deserve the equal amount of,
of attention and resources
for these massive tournaments that go on
and make the NCAA so much money.
(upbeat music)